non ho ancora capito e continuerà a non
capirlo
l tutti ragazzi e prevenuti avessero
video sono vari j
e come tutti i primi mercoledì del mese
se lo sono un episodio di game tester
a me mettere la sigla mi gasa un sacco
non so perché mette di nuovo
purché sia ragazzi iniziamo che se
bisogna sua e sigla la smetto lasme
prima di cominciare ragazzi voleva
nominare il gangster del mese c'è chi ha
vinto lo scorso episodio di in testa di
cartoon network che è stato luca de che
ti faccio da roma da roman scusate
voglio anche menzionare però francesco
da palermo che ha fatto un grandissimo
video anche lui quindi meritava di
essere nominato bravissimi tra questi
ragazzi passiamo al gioco gli occhi sei
ragazzi su free for all
quando ha un disperato bisogno di tdp
rimpinguare i suoi follower online per
fortuna grizzly rosso bianco prendono in
mano la situazione perfetto da una mano
ai tre fratelli orsi a scovare le
avventure più giuste da postare è una
casa social e bellissimi anni avanti
posso provare prima panda panda self e
bellissima erano parole utilizzati
adesivi per aiutare parlando a creare il
self i perfetto lato questa cosa che ci
appaga sul fianco destro ce l'ho anch'io
siamo uguali perfetto voglio fare un
cell t con lui prima o poi ragazzi
scatta una foto a panda eccola lì vai
che un figo modello trascinare gli esiti
giusti sulla sua faccia per accumulare
punti ed energia calmi calmi occhio che
questo questo non c'entra una mazza
ok mamma mia è stata la cosa più
difficile della vita ancora da tempo
devo muovermi pure meraviglioso ragazzi
sarà difficile ho visto di peggio tipo
che mario era peggiorato l'occhiale
maledizione cosa c'è ancora se vuoi alle
stelle
ciò fatto dio in tempo assoluto proprio
a diventa sempre più difficile certo
punto non uscirò più sicura ma già
adesso faccio difficoltà non ci credo
ok ci ho fatto miracolo posso fare il
record del mondo lega non ne sono
sicurissimo selphy strepitoso sempre il
piu cosi addosso un certo punto non si
capirà neanche più che un panda dai dai
no a naro arianesi cosa manca derivativa
che non ci credo mai non ci si è chiuso
tutto fatto un casino a 445
dai pensavo peggio solo una schiappa
queste cose non al serio anche perché io
per farmi senti comunque sono uguale
ragazze orso bianco e lo zen aiuta orso
bianco ad eseguire alla perfezione tutte
le mosse durante l'allenamento è questa
la vedo più difficile ancora traccia tre
linee per realizzare una mossa
portentosa ad accumulare energia
ho capito mi fa iniziarono ok a da
quando partita perfetta scivolata
perfetto ma qual è scivolata cioè le
idee confuse amico mio sono comunque sai
calmo sta ammazzando
oddio ho fatto simboli degli illuminati
ragazzo il quale scivola milena
scivolata ma 666 illuminati coincidenze
non credo solo resistendo e ragazzi se
non so no dai
perfetta per questo non ci prometti
se te l'ho fatta sì certo mi faccio
anche milano roma avanti indietro 6
vogliono so scivolata perfetta si è
fatto meglio in questo che nell'altro
prova grizzly che credo che voglia
mangiare poi assaggiare a grizzly il
cibo del mercato locale
re degli assaggi mamma mia mamma mia
mamma mia mamma mia mamma mia
rega sta diventando un fenomeno ma che
abbia passato la mia vita giocare a sta
roba non impossibile madonna mi sta
dando quello sbagliato vai qui no
mancata la caramella per la mancata
consisterà meglio come l'anatra nella
una caramella carmela rea carmela laganà
e larga nel regolamento regala caramella
caramella raganella ma grave è la grotta
ottimo ottima non ottimo perché potevo
fare di meglio ma lo ragazzi credo che
possiate fare di meglio di me dimostrate
meno passato al prossimo che meglio
rugby mx clicca invio per gioco si mio
questo invio c'è scritto invio non va
capiscimi a ok ho già scritto premi
invio ma in realtà dove schiacciare sul
livello onore a proviamo a fare il primo
non so quanto adesso invece devo premere
invio
hai le idee confuse fratello si può
partire
oddio come si fa andare avanti a dio
cos'è è una cosa replica sembra è più il
solo a prendere lo sapevo lo prendi di
fantasmi spiega ma di comandi ormai
spiegato niente se si abbassasse di più
è un figo è un figo dovrei riuscire ad
arrivare di sopra perfetto siano due
e niente sono tutti così giusto tre
fantasmi livello finito prendi il tasto
per continuare questa la vedo più di
quindi rimane sempre più difficile salve
è proprio il mio tipo di ragazze e
ragazzi andiamo avanti
cos'è ho preso un fantasmino ancora
senza vederlo dove sta andando
e dopo questa ragazzi scatta l'applauso
non so perché arrivi saltare zio
si no no si no sono incastrato ma non ci
crede la marina ha steccato
non ho parole è stato difficile però
sono riuscito a salvare lei per caso un
virus dell serve passare in salute anche
voi fantastico ce l'ho fatta lega ci ha
messo mezz'ora a fare questo però ne è
valsa la pena grande spinta
non so perché ci sono certi momenti in
cui mi sembra troppo e più si sente
osservato ragazzi
penso che sia una mia fissazione
e vabbè allora non stava scherzando
impossibile devo scendere sul che non ci
arriva ma mi sono salvato come come mi
sono salvato non lo so ho fatto una cosa
mamma mia
non fatelo ma non so come ho fatto
riportate ragazzi non è vincere ma
raccogliere i fantasmini e fargli capire
chi comanda in questo caso non io perché
ho fatto una cosa stupida
avevo lì ma un metro come ho fatto a
mancarlo perfetto
l'importante è riprendersi siamo quasi
alla fine mancano due livelli ragazzi di
vent'anni incasina tello è comunque a
parte gli scherzi sono gli altri
ho visto la morte in faccia
siamo due manca il terzo che non ho la
più pallida idea di dove si possa
addirittura addirittura destra sistema
ci stiamo evolvendo ragazzi mamma cosa
ho fatto è tanta roba progaming per
stupidi non problemi in corsa mi salvo
mi salvo bis con salvato come ho fatto
ammesso in transilvania sono andati a
metterlo ragazzi però non potete
metterli così vista magari un po di
contegno a lei ea una mazza mezz'ora
livello 12 siamo all'ultimo ragazzi ne
manca uno e ho finito
sarebbe un miracolo mi spiegate il ruolo
dei blues tel in questo videogame voglio
capirlo non ho ancora capito e
continuerà a non capirlo perché non ha
senso
che prova a prendere un po più di
rincorsa perché è la cosa più stupida
che abbia mai fatto morire così ok
orobie ok va bene va bene va bene
sono arrivata la fine è arrivato alla
fine di te io come premio permettetevi
ragazzi voglio farmi i capelli così ciao
ragazzi con quello che l'episodio è
stata tra questi due videogame è stata
la cosa più strana della storia se
volete provare adesso non chi vuoi che
in testa nel mese andate su
www.cartoonnetwork.it che apparso sopra
mio dito magicamente sono un mago
filmate di mentre giocate il mandate il
vostro video gameplay è provato a
diventare in testa del mese che
ovviamente nominero nel prossimo
episodio questo video altre essere
presente sul mio canale anche presente
sul canale di cartoon network italia e
va in onda anche su cartoon network
quindi se volete rivederlo potete
vederlo anche l'aiuto in più non mi
l'episodio ragazzi come al solito
seguite più lasciato commento è un mi
piace questa cosa ha senso perché se
questo episodio va in tv io spengo la tv
di tutti quelli che guardano non è vero
sto scherzando quei ragazzi servite per
il suo canto mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non vi sia stata una
descrizione senza doversi discrezione ci
vediamo il fiorito bella ragazza